welcome everybody and this is an
interactive workshop so you suspect to
do some coding maybe there will be some
material left over to be a home do at
home exercise because it's a short
format so yeah there's seven parts we're
hoping to get we really want to get to
part three in the hour we might get to
part four so easy but it's self-guided
as well so you can just keep going if
you want to so a couple of things quick
things of that sitter setup you can use
no ten plus so if you have no 12 is fine
and but but if you do have issues switch
to this version because that's what it's
written against originally and does
everyone know and understand and have
installed nvm anyone don't
how does anyone not have an nvm
installed okay kukuku
so we're going to clone a repository
we're assuming everyone knows how to use
get if anyone doesn't talk to your
neighbor talk to us
so oh yeah we're gonna do that in a
minute what a react hooks
a react took is a essentially like a
mini state machine it's a reusable
staple function and it doesn't obstruct
the view hierarchy versus other ways of
managing state and react
I there's a seat just there at the front
if you can find it
no ten you want also near forum booth so
here's an example of a react hug this is
one is consist conceptually this ysus
requires some levers just like you know
for talking purposes so say we have a
library that has a used API hook so the
use API hook would be used within a
function component and it would return
an object from which we do D structure
the parameter the keys error and name
the the second value here would be like
what the initial value should be which
is where name is loading so the first
value of name would be loading so when
it renders the h2 element in the the JSX
there it would first say loading the use
the API hook would go and query the make
make the asynchronous call when that
call resolves it would trigger a
rerender with that new value and the
second time it's called the use API hook
would return an object where the name is
whatever that user's name is that
correlates with the ID do you understand
so this is the flow of how hooks work
there is rent you're not awaiting your
your rendering and then your rear
entering which is the react way and the
major difference is you move away from
classes yeah
in react and just use functions which is
way for me makes it understandable I
could never understood react with use
classes so sorry just you know quick
admission here and just these make me
use react and lovely yeah anyway yeah
and I also agree but it did this is this
is a much more self-contained kind of
encapsulated way to work with react in
our opinion
so what hooks do is they allow you to
store and manage local state state it
allows you to have a separation of
concerns that ties into what we're
saying about classes so if you have a
class and you have to define how it gets
at State and different things and then
you have class inheritance involved in
that too
things can get coupled quite quickly but
if you're using hooks particularly if
you've written them yourself then you
can kind of update that functionality
across your application quite easily and
that's where it comes into the functions
versus classes which we've just covered
so graph QL is a data query language
okay it's it's it was it was born at
Facebook a long time ago to to build an
API that can represent the entirety of
Facebook whatever this means what is
useful for well it has some very a lot
of very nice properties which is itself
evolving you can evolve it you don't
need to version it and it's really
powerful it's it schema based so you
write a schema you get the graphical
schema and then you provide some
functions and called resolvers to
populate that data it also
strongly-typed so you can actually
define your types and everything would
work now it's nothing it's nothing
related to typescript okay so I don't
worry about that every different thing
it's also self documenting which is for
me the most critical the most nice
feature of this and what it enables at
create a mento of productivity so you
can actually explore the API using some
tools that which you will see if you're
not familiar with them and it's actually
very powerful because of this it's it
shortened up the development cycle of
not all I need to think about these rest
api blah blah blah instead you can just
add some more data terms some more some
more something more into the schema and
just about the day it's if it has fewer
run it provides fewer round trips so in
a normal traditional rest application if
you want to fetch three the data for for
your app needs to do three holes or over
HTTP instead of doing three holes you
can just set your graph you out and
point all the ones asking for all the
tree three pieces of data and will
automatically bring it back to you which
is really powerful too
provide a better performance on the on
the front end of your system and it also
provides a little bit smaller payloads
because of all of this so what is a
graph QL hooks graph QL hooks are it's a
library that we have written an ear for
to provide a smaller version a smaller a
minimal way of using graph QL with hooks
with reactives and it's you know you
probably familiar with Apollo Apollo is
kind of big compared to what what you
are aiming to do with real with
graphical hooks this is tiny and it was
really well and it's it's really
lightweight it's a few kilobytes to add
to your to your bundle compared to -
Apollo mm right
let's clone the first URL the second URL
is just to for your interest it's the
library that we're going to be using
we'll keep this up until everyone's got
that clone because we can't really
proceed until you've done that
you can your picture all tribes I guess
what people are cloning if anyone has
any questions they want to shout out on
a discussion while that's happening
feel free or if not we can just sit here
in awkward silence Hey
yes yeah there it's good it's a good is
actually what I wanted to see him react
in the first place yes like years ago
but I'm glad that they actually went to
that place in the end
no only with function components
well it's that's that's how they've I
think they're trying to move people
towards that by making that call
it was yeah it was yes because es6
classes were introduced so they followed
that trend of es6 classes and then they
another come back to the original kind
of simple idea which is great like we
have a problem in this industry where
people add complexity for the sake of
adding complexity because they think it
makes them look good this is recorded a
might not okay
I mean to me I think like if you know
what makes people look good to me is
when they found an elegant and simple
solution to something and we actually I
do actually really like Raph looks for
that have you cloned this okay have
anybody had any problems cloning okay
fine
the same thing yep so first part one
correct
yes they are fully interoperable so you
can use a class component in sidewalks
and vice versa right yes yes but you
can't use hooks inside of a class
component so with so say for instance
the reactor use effect it's kind of
analogous to the component did mount
lifecycle method I think so there's
there's analogs so first of all the
goals of the first step is get a
graphical server up and running and
explored that server using graphic graph
iql graphical graphical yeah graphical
so what you're going to use you're going
to choose no js' okay it's no process
interactive so maybe it's wrong you have
the wrong conference if you want to use
another language we're going to use
FASTA Phi
hey I'm Matteo I kind of started fast if
I with Thomas like back in 2016 so it's
a long time ago I had some ideas you had
some idea going see me anywhere near it
but I was probably it was part of it the
original ideas about all of this please
check it out it's part of opens a yes
foundation and so on so you know
trade-off and we're going to use react
okay yeah it's reactive so I don't have
to react and we're gonna do some
graphical stuff so you can check
yourself the first thing you do you're
going to the exercise folder part one l
word run npm install and ran ran and PM
run watch yeah so that you know it
automatically restart when you make
changes so you don't need to you know
restart the process manually this is
also going to take a little little time
to do because npm install' it's a little
bit slow because of the Wi-Fi and so on
so and then you want to go to local lost
3,000 hmm come on in we got floor space
floor space she's at me is there's a
chair here in his chariot if it almost a
chair for their back or whatever the
chair here check out here after you're
back guys we want to take care of your
house and just wash up you see anyone
need some help with this
oh good okay well that's uh oh no no
wait they've got do it yeah yeah yeah do
it do it give us a nod when you're done
we'll check in in a second oh yeah
you
I've already installed us
so you should see
that should be your end result after
you've run npm run watch should have a
server listening one two seven zero zero
one three thousand and if you open that
it will be this hello world thing and
you could list users you can add a user
in add matteo well if we refresh it it
disappears and so what we're going to do
is we're gonna add that server-side
state using graphic URL we're with with
we I took
you
where do you live
okay it's not using the ocean
did you given
okay has everyone been able to load
localhost 3000 and see ya okay fantastic
the beautiful HelloWorld application you
see we have really good CSS developers
you know so we just tile we just choose
not to do it
we're minimalist okay so if you go to
the list users page you can see as I
just showed you you can add a name if
you refresh it'll disappear because we
haven't connected up graph QL dot dot
dot yeah yeah so everyone take a look at
in the source server folder as a graphic
you all that yes file
I'll open as well
by the way in the thing that you cloned
probably want you in the repo that you
cloned you also have this this
index.html file so you can look at the
slide there - on your machine
so
this graphic J's file
we're requiring faster fire gql which is
a module written by Matteo we'll go into
details on that in a second don't get
too excited we have just like a mocked
data we don't we're not using a database
and take too long but you get the idea
this is a placeholder for you know data
storage of an array of users we have two
schemas which we're going to go into
details of two types yeah to tight ones
key Metrotech yeah one schema sorry to
graft you all types one called user one
called cute query query has a user's key
with an array of types of user so this
is basically saying this is an array of
objects with the names which are strings
which is describing this here no
and then we have resolvers which is
basically the counterpart that you give
to FASTA file to say this is how we
handle a particular type in the schema
so we only have one defined for queried
and it has a user's method which
corresponds to this users key and we
return the user list array from that and
here we have the lip lock in the first
fi plugging that registers justified ql
with our schema where there is overs and
notably we set graphing ql or graphical
to true because
if you still have your server running
yes you can go to is a for such graphic
you holidays you know so go to localhost
3000
for / graphic UL the HTML
yeah you missed the edge
I miss the age you know I can I can
always put in a typo in here all the
time
you know done okay okay so now we have
like wait you when you when you open
your UI you won't see this query
variables piece it'll be down here but
your you might want to just pull that up
for later you'll see why so one of the
greatest thing about grab about
graphical is that you can actually you
know what you can say you can open up
this and then if you start typing you
automate here out of completion and you
can add in line docs to your you can you
can add in line dogs to to your comment
to it to your error solvers so you can
basically said I want users okay and so
and then you can actually say for
example and then you can specify the
property the properties that you want
and you say name again and you close
note that if you open dogs you will see
the drop of the route types those are
the ones that are attached to the query
object so that you know it's you can
actually explore this and search it and
navigate it completely so a graphic
graphic well graphical is fully sub
describing yes
yes so if you open dogs you can actually
say for example you say you see users
then you can click on users I need to
tell you the fields no you need to stay
the key part there is reducing the
payloads so you want to know long reload
the data that are you that you need so
you you know you want to know which
fields you want so that's because that's
a key part of this so you don't want to
return all the full object because my
object of my serum database can have I
don't know 100 fields but if I can only
ship five two or three of those fields
you know I don't need to develop a
version of map of the of my API for my
mobile app that requires less fields I
came back and just connect to the same
graphical and point of the web app that
needs more fields so it don't need to
actually implement the same API twice
for different clients so it is really
powerful if if you think it like that
especially it's a way for teams to
communicate then you can press ENTER you
can press play and it automatically
works which is pretty powerful because
you can explore and develop your queries
while using you using these these
development environments that are
already part of the graph care ecosystem
and it's really really really really
powerful at least for me from my point
of view
so we okay so one of the things of a
fast if I graphed you are ggq out that
you that we have developed is the is
about performance so you might want to
check this out if you're already using
graph QL because first if I gql is
actually fast and we have done a lot of
distance amount of research and I'll
talk to my is graph QL we've done the
last year at this conference mathias
booth and myself did a talk call graph
you all accelerated if you are
interested you might want to check that
out and it's a pretty goes into deep
into why and how we have optimized it
how we have optimized it graph you out
yeah this is the graphical is actually a
hard problem and and because it's
solving something that that if you
design your api is really well in the
first place and they're though they come
from the client in the first place like
you're you're driving it from like a UI
perspective then you could theoretically
try to design a system without graph QL
graph UL comes into play when you need
to aggregate a lot of AP is that you
haven't had control over right and so
but what it's doing is application joins
yeah so an application join is obviously
usually a very bad idea you want to do
that in a database that's gonna be more
efficient so this is actually a hard
problem in node because we're you're
trading off a lot of different things so
performance is very hard for for for
this kind of thing so first why gql is
like pretty amazing but the one thing it
doesn't have yet Matteo federated
Federation yeah Federation so if you're
in a Palo you can have you can you can
distribute your graph you old schemas
across basically an organization
phosphide gqr needs that if you want to
see that with performance you got a dr.
hit him on on github so were you all
able to run the query
fantastic one more thing that first
offensive QL does which is pretty
amazing it does it compiles the queries
the graphical queries into JavaScript
functions in a safe way so what it does
is essentially just you know take your
graphical and clearing validates it and
then compiling down to a really fast
JavaScript function that then it's
evaluated and executed and we cast that
function so because of that we can save
a lot of the time a lot of time that is
spent into validating the query caching
the query a validating the query and
compiling the period
yes and no so it's to some extent it's a
similar but the problem is that
persistent queries do not do that on the
other so that the implementation of
persistent we did not do that all of
this is done at runtime so essentially
is cached within the same process so it
is slightly different technique it's the
same kind of constant but a different
technique so if your surface service
still running run this query and see
that you get the result just make sure
that everyone's working as if it's
working for you
if we run ourselves yes
yes we did okay so everyone who's run it
have you seen this this output yeah yeah
okay part two I think we're gonna make
it to part three yeah so part 2 the
graph QL schema we're gonna update the
schema to create a user so we're not
just going to query the users we're
gonna start creating users and we're
going to test it with graphical or
graphic QL whatever so going to the
second part to exercise so you have to
run npm install again run npm run watch
again same pattern and go to localhost
3000
yes absolutely yeah stop the first one
otherwise you'll have a poor conflict
you
everyone got their yeah still waiting
okay
so let's take a look at the graph QL
guess in part two source server so
how she really liked working with the
font this big so much nicer on the eyes
so in the graphic I guess in part two we
still have the user list we've got some
to-do items everything else I think is
the same so we're going to start editing
this file and on the to-do list you say
we're going to add a mutation type to
schema we're going to add a create using
mutation we're going to take a parameter
and we're going to return a user type
from schema so let's do that so graph
your schema defines the relationships
and the structures of the data nothing
to really elaborate on there is a so one
of the key things off of graph QL is
that you have this typed object that can
return types are the types object and
other types object another object it's
and it defines the relationship between
things let's say that you have a dog
that you have a type dog and the type
person you can say you can create a
property on the type person that says da
it dogs and that returns the dogs for
that person now these will colors
different resolvers so what you can do
is you can structure your code into in a
way so that all this all these various
concerns are separated and it actually
works pretty well because you can
actually think about different features
on your application and implement them
very quickly based of this because the
what's most well are brown yeah maybe
and so you know in the schema in our
graph geology as well this is what it
currently looks like the resolvers as
we've explained are the functions that
are the counterparts to the schema but
the queries are fetching so we have this
query in our schema but mutations are
for writing so
obviously some of you probably know this
but we're just making sure that we're
all on the same page as we get to the
hook spot so to create user we're going
to add a mutation to the schema and we
enter the counter part of it to the
resolvers in our graphic yo GS so at the
bottom of the schema if we add this in
here type of mutation create user name
string with an exclamation point they
call this a non nullable type okay
otherwise known as require required
it's a non level we need to require what
a weird way to say required it's non
nullable which is required right I don't
know it's I'm sorry just depends if you
are a positive person or an really
negative you see here you can see
negative logic or positive logic I don't
know it depends on how you write your
sentences
has everyone been able to add to this
yet still some people working on it
I hear a couple of Keys clicking away so
you need to put them into the model the
top-level mutation but I would put them
yes
these are top level things but now you
can make things a little bit more
complicated with the nesting and objects
but you need to have a top level entry
point so the only top level entry points
that your application can use our query
and rotation so the rest is known top
level so you know but I could
cool everyone good everyone got this
into their schema now we're going to do
the resolver so in the resolvers object
we need to add a mutation key capital m
and then that key holds an object which
has a method called create user
oh shoot after looking - what's the
underscore for is the current object so
it's a mutation of it don't work alright
so the mutation this is your design no
it's not myself oh yeah so one of the
key things about graphical is that you
can always return the current object so
if you're actually creating query or
mutating something in a big tree you can
always refer to the parent object on
that on that chain and that is that
underscore but even that mutation is the
root object we don't need it so we call
it underscore and forget it it's a
little bit functional style putting it
as underscore so I don't know if you're
familiar with one of those functional
language we put underscore when you
don't need it basically means I don't
care about this parameter right
well you would use the object in yeah so
you typically you use those objects a
lot when you query so if you're feeling
a big graph structure you can you want
to know for example which you know if
you have a person that has a dog you
want to know when you're calling writing
there are shoulder dog you want to know
which person you are asking the dog for
and that data will be in that parameter
make sense okay so in the mutation
resolver we're just pushing to the user
list obviously this is just for the
purposes of of learning because you
don't want stateful services you want to
purchase a database right everyone good
okay so we're going to test that
mutation in graphi cool so if you still
got your server running go or if you
haven't you to start it with NPM run
watch logos three thousand four slash
graphic you all that HTML and make sure
remember I said like that little hidden
almost hidden panel where it's like your
variables make sure you've got that
ready because we're going to use that in
a second now has everyone been able to
load the graphical graphical UI for part
two
okay I'm seeing yes as I'm not seeing
nose so we shall proceed we might want
to test it first
oh yeah oh yeah surely you're right yeah
this is it
so we go into you can book by the way
and gets off the slides if you don't
want to hand type it so how you need to
round the pad to me I'm not right oh
sure you keep killing it I don't know
why
muscle memory yeah I know
you haven't already
refresh yep so first we need to put this
in no not that
yeah the copy-paste on the slides is
annoying because when you try to copy it
goes to the next slide so we put that in
there the query variables down here we
also need to add and I'm just going to
do it and you can kind of see it
the query variables here because this is
uh this is essentially a variable kind
of a variable that you define in the
schema and then the query variables are
then passed to finish order the resolver
and one of the key thing about using
this type of using query variables it's
because it's like I don't know sequel I
mean if you're familiar with sequel
hopefully everybody you probably have
seen like there is question marks when
you put put that put the things down you
don't concatenate a string for all sorts
of problems like sequel injections and
all whatever issue you can imagine query
variables are the exact same thing so
you use them when you specify parameters
you don't concatenate that string into
that make sense run it oh wait let's run
it oh I'm probably I mean totally
because we didn't do it right okay hold
on hold on you have you go I'm gonna go
to one I made earlier easy it's
yeah you need to refreshment it's not
yeah but you to refresh yeah whoo that's
what you should see if you see the other
thing you didn't do it right like me so
then you can actually and then if you go
back to the query
then you can see that Bob's been added
okay anyone a here called Bob guest of
honor
oh no Bob come on
no Roberts I guess that names fallen out
of fashion then yeah I like the way
Uncle Bob then sorry oh you're showing
the data in yo to the resolver it's not
there not there go to the slides okay
yeah so if we go back to the slides for
a second go back go back up at one Ford
yeah she eat so we'll see is pushing it
to the list user list is an array again
just for learning purposes and we don't
recommended and you destroy an array for
your state and in your process but we
just push like that mutation resolver
cools create user yes and for the
purposes of this workshop one of the
things that is interesting here is that
if you use you both create users and
users can be a sync function so you can
use the async function and promises to
write your result nice okay does it make
sense we're nearly at the hook spot and
we still have time so yeah yeah rushing
for us through towards the goal so here
okay here we are
part three is to get to okay foundation
laid so the goals of part three we
wanted check out this graph QL hooks
library see in action I want to hook up
the backend data the front-end web page
we want to retrieve a list of users from
an API using a graph go hook so if you
go into part three or you can continue
if you got part 2 working you can
continue working on that however you
want to do it but anyone who wants to
make sure that you know they're starting
fresh go to part 3 amp you install NPM
run watch
you
you
you
everyone there yeah mmm stores fast
today in the same folder we're gonna
might need to open a new tab well you
might need to control C and then running
him wrong watch again have you wanna do
it but we want to do NPM install graph
QL hooks so we're gonna bring this graph
your hooks librarian right now download
it
you
the pushin if we push the new leaves out
this morning Oh
[Laughter]
you know you deploy on Fridays right so
if it doesn't work raise your hand
they all raise their hand there we are
going to play Ryan yeah I just want to
by the way we're here opera I just want
to shout out to Brian Mullen which is
was the hi Brian hi Brian the original
author of Garfield hooks so we have a
season shaped support for graphical
subscriptions which is a long
conversation topic for to support like
live data both on graphical looks and
fast if I take you out in the last month
so pretty good work a deterministic a
few hooks
okay so in a source client dress app -
LJ s we want to import the graph your
client from graphical hooks and then we
need to set it up
so internally all the graphical query
goes to / - - L by D you could have made
that the default yeah you maybe should
so and
[Music]
great what have you done so we're going
to was a client jazz app shell and we
want to import the graph to our client
and we want to instantiate the graphic
to our client and then we can probably
remove important instantiate
good anchor point three and oh yeah
so that's that to do done
you
yeah
you
so these are long topic yeah you know
broad hello my the current breaking
where the industry is going most of time
is using a JSON web tokens most of
that's what goes for possibly the one of
the most white fried solutions budget to
keep the services stateless yes because
you would like to keep your sources and
the other that's a standard way to
actually encode a token somewhere and
then you need can store that token
whatever you want or regenerate it
refreshing it's really is a we're very
well done standard and I would just
recommend to use that and not random
okay everyone got that
no frowns all the Fran's are upside
okay the next part is in the same file
we want to add that client into the we
want to wrap a provider all right does
anyone know how react providers were
correct provider in context so react
context is essentially a way to do sort
of lateral state is there happened to
pass properties all the way down through
two components we can rapper a provider
around a component and then we can
access that that context from any
component in that tree
later on so it's kind of like a little
bit of a trapdoor so order dependency
injection the pencil a dependency
injection I don't know I'd get it you
know a bit sort of narrative with it
narration talk about it for like a day
yeah
so what we'd like we we've got this here
but actually you don't need to redo
placate that you can just say I'm gonna
add client context into my imports like
this right
and then we're gonna wrap the client
context provider around
the app shell
and then we say the value of that
provider is client yes
so if we get these all in
so when we when you set the value of a
provider you can hurt you can import
that client context somewhere else and
then you can say client context of
consumer wrap that around your component
and then suddenly you have access to
that client
yes
yes but this is this is this is now the
graph QL Hookes library which is
front-end yeah
yeah we're pointing it out pacified so
yeah partying at a fancy feature yeah
trying if we add our own context like
our custom context for react we just
wrap it above this or we have to
you can wrap it above
that right yeah I don't understand if
you went without that context you can
just wrap that oh yeah you get a
multiple contact you can have as many as
you want there's also you instead of
using client context consumer there's
also a use context react hook so then
you can just use a hook to get your
context once you've wrapped it which is
quite elegant
has everyone got this part great now
we're going to set up in source app
pages list users Jes we're going to take
those queries that we're playing with
earlier in graphical and we're going to
you know put them into that file as
upper case list users query and create
users mutation
source app pages source app pages list
users so they go outside of the function
right yeah
so that's what that's what we're doing
we're adding this two source app pages
list users j/s adding these two queries
that we were playing with earlier
well one query one mutation
and we're just about
a magical part where we actually use a
hook
wait I'm just coming we can't hear you
from it
the schema has been duplicated right
because we had you stop the schema and
the server - yes well yes will that
always be the case do you have to
duplicate it or do you like project and
you can probably import it there is so
this this is not the schema
these are queries oh yeah there are
types they're not type types are in the
types aren't on the other side these
specified the queries so this reason we
use these queries in graphical earlier
that's why you recognize them but
they're not actually in the server sorry
I miss I was incorrect there
you
you
stole some typing so we're gonna
we still have half an hour we can do
more we can do part 4 we could we could
start pop for at least see it's part 7 7
parts of this yeah we weren't worried
about whether we had enough content
okay I'm hearing a couple of keys still
typing so it would sway a few more
minutes they won two minutes
you
any questions
you see no you're not almost not typing
any more it's good okay it's good all
right
so also unless users yes we're gonna use
the youths query hook from graph QL
hooks so here we're importing it as my
lovely assistant just helped to display
and then with this this piece here needs
to be inside the actual component
because you can only use hooks inside of
components else it doesn't work reactor
would complain badly yeah I mean there's
there's very good reason for that
because they actually use the fact that
you've used it in the component to
actually track the state so that's why
you can't use it without so the use
query hook returns an object with a data
and a refetch key the data key is the
the data that is fetched by the query
and we do an assignment as we're
destructuring that object we also assign
a default value of an object with a
user's key and an empty array so that we
don't have issues where we means we can
just map over an empty array later on
right yes it's users type is users tied
to our query which part yes the list
users query yes yes called something
else if we change the shape no so this
is your constant you have a Content area
we just did here that's that caught that
constant yeah okay so it's nothing
lazily the types hmm no it because of
the texting there you can collect Bob if
you want to or fubar when we define
their schema we had users as a property
that was formally defined
oh yes yes so that won't change no all
of this code is stable yes yes right the
key traffic evolving graph QL is I'm
writing SQL applique based application
is that you do not change things you
just just add more properties more
solvers more types you do not remove any
in this way old clients can still work
so for example if you write a mobile app
you can actually have used different
graphic you out you can use the same
queries but with different properties
and then you have multiple versions of
that app being server at the same
graphical and point even if you add more
types and more queries to support new
features so you don't need to it's
essentially it shows one of the problems
of REST API that you have those nice
version numbers in those REST API I
don't know if you love them but whatever
I like them I like those version numbers
okay so I've put it into I'm in the
right place let's do this yeah so I put
it into the list users J's file so we
have import you squared from graphical
hooks at the top and then within our
exported list users function component
we at the very top of that we have this
cool to use query and as we're just
discussing we pass in the list users
query constant into the use query hook
and so what's going to happen is what we
need to do some more setup but what what
can happen then is that use query can
asynchronously call the server as I was
talking about earlier with the use API I
concept concept the initial state will
just be a data with an empty uses array
when that query resolves it can re
render that list users component with
that with that state
Mayson so far has everyone got this down
yeah cool
so the data the used query returns a
data key and that's the JSON that's
passed Jason that's received on the API
and a refetch function so you can
trigger a refetch potentially with I
guess a button yeah or maybe when you do
an action so yeah if you want to if you
change the data you might want to affect
that so again in the same in the same
file we're gonna be structure the the
the use mutation hook from the graph
your hooks library so we don't have to
do as a separate import we can just do
this this here
you can remove line from three to six
okay all right yeah I'm also gonna
remove all this scanning the way yeah
okay so if everyone got the used
mutation hook imported and then we can
use the user mutation hook it also
inside our function component we'll put
it underneath use query
so use mutation returns an array where
the first element of that array is the
function that's used to call that
mutation so we're calling it create user
we can call it whatever we want when we
do structure an array
is everyone familiar with these
structuring yeah pretty neat I like it
just don't you like your children they
just don't nest your destructuring
because that's crazy
don't do that keep it dislike go on a
new line and destructure the next thing
otherwise it gets to be insane we than a
machine requested recently I'm not
called to remove some very nasty
destruction that rebooting for some
reason nice
uh-huh
right here so refetch is is aliased to
refresh users with the fracturing yeah
so when you do structure you can
actually alias one key to another key
using a colon
right no we're not using it yet but it's
right here now that the Declaration of
that available so the the so used query
returns an object with a refetch key
court function yeah you got it
okay yeah you can remove line 30
13:30
oh yeah now that yeah just keep the
function but remove the sir yeah yeah
okay and now in create new user we want
to turn that into an async function
because currently it's not
does everyone familiar with async/await
yeah do you like us you can wait okay
have you watched well compromises talked
with him so now here's not fun is your
mind still all intact anyhow okay yeah
just yeah
it requires thought this is the problem
with like easy to learn hard to master
it's pretty much the motto of JavaScript
and it's still going with async/await
so we got this remember we got this
create user function that we've
destructured as from the first element
of the user mutation hook we're now
gonna use that it returns a promise so
we can await the results of that in our
create a new user function right here
which is in turn used in this onclick
handler so we await the create new user
function passing variables pass in name
which we're getting from the use state
hook here initially that's going to be
set to nothing but we can set the name
with a name is set in the the info field
here when you when you had a name so
this variables property that you that
you prat passed to create user an object
with the property variables it's saying
I want to set the variable of my
mutation which is name right so that
that gets passed in on the on the server
side
similar to how we did name Bob in the
query variables panel that we had to
lift up same thing
raaaah
oh and we also want to do Refik refresh
users after we create a new user so then
you've got like a an immediate update
from adding that user
yeah
he protects right well though so I'm not
familiar that much with react but when
you do set name want you updating the
state which will trigger a rerender
which in itself will redo the used query
which will refresh the user's on its own
so why you need to refresh again so it
does now that you know that it's memo
the data is memorized automatically so
we're not referring that you calling the
graphical API and it's every time we are
just calling it once and then cased
cached data and when you call refresh
you actually fetch get the data again
otherwise you'd end up in continuous
Varner because you're not calling set
your own OCONUS that name in create a
new user it's a it's all maintaining in
the local stage
these are good questions yes yeah so
when is the types of flash from memory
so if if any data used do that you will
get with use query is stating memorized
when is it flash from memory do you keep
it in local storage memory or it's
attached to the the component so it's
not connected to okay to other stuff so
it's basically when the component goes
out of scope which is how hooks work at
a call away if for whatever reason
instead of doing the queries in in
components themselves you want it to do
it let's say in one centralized spot on
an app startup you just want to get
everything like a big app state you
would just need a component to do that
you just taking one combined you pass
whatever to do that yeah but what about
the reef fetches because let's say
individual things need to know let's
believe you could pass the refetch
function down if you wanted to yeah yeah
or is context
okay good great questions guys loving it
that name is the set state function
which is just this is just a normal
reactor called you state if you know
about hooks you'll be familiar with you
state it's kind of a core piece it
returns an array with the the value of
the state and then an updated function
we call it set name because we can
oh gosh or apart for no we can try that
today you want to ran that oh yeah right
yeah you might want to ran eat I don't
know all right okay okay so what we can
do and we can run watch he made me wrong
yeah might be wrong I might need to fix
it yay
here you go oh I didn't install it yeah
do what I say not what I do apparently
yeah
no we also send and load we're using use
query to load the data
oh yeah they need to update the thing
sorry sorry second what's happening you
need to all right yeah you need to do
data instead of users you need to put
down no the accusers it's fine it's fine
yeah but we need to disclose it no no
Dave is fine because it's already put
his users it's fine
you don't need to do anything you should
work no it won't just try it no work
because the users is here inside of data
so yeah but yeah okay yeah so we have to
do constant users
yeah but they think it was data yeah
okay so if you add this line to line two
underneath you can do Const destructor
users from data because there's a user's
array in there that you need to get rid
of or and then that will be then mapped
over in this you know well element so
before we can progress
let's try native structure yeah well it
will work this will work okay I'm pretty
confident it'll work
staking my reputation on it cool
no cool what open Hey look at today look
at the control what is the
he is not banned incorrectly
oh really
yeah
when in doubt remove node modules
total package luck if you have that yeah
package lock has caused us some issues
hmm or shrink-wrapping
at least shrink-wrap is kind of like an
explicit opt-in
you
all right is this your update no it's so
funny [ __ ] are they
hey Jessica
is it working for somebody well you're a
better
than me
that would be a good one thank you thank
you pair programming
mm so cray user Dave do myself
yeah you could just end it yeah refresh
and it's still there
okay so you should be able to do that
we go unable to do it
because we will not see a tour without
hope okay who needs help
I might not be the best person but
you
oh you've not
sorry go back no go back to use mutation
that way where is it you just showed me
it yeah you're not um you're not calling
it you just say yeah you got a pass in
the create users mutation
yeah
they're their users
uh-huh
where is the error sorry what line okay
go to that lines right
yeah that's it Beaufort okay so it's
where you're trying to do structure from
you since the use of you that says user
query not usually
reasoning what say loud
oh no no not like anyone else or
everyone else got this working nice
over here
you
so you state one people you call set
name
values Malaysia the same thing every
fight
so we called reefer
yeah yeah yeah
next one America let me see it let us
now I'm messy steadily not many humans
Oh worry yes any hooks are using prefix
with news
you can you can yes you can I don't but
you can
yeah sorry this is actually a good
question so you might want to say it
loud I was wondering if you could use
typescript to help keep track of all the
different schema consistencies that you
need to create across this I think that
depends if you if you if you bought into
typescript then probably but if you've
not then don't don't use typescript to
do this it's a I think there's just a
completely different paradigm and it's
an opt-in kind of things like you need
the whole house to get the kitchen sink
I like typescript for the DTS Wells
because I think that has my value and
like across all and I like typescript
because it can process GS doc so that's
completely opt-in and you can just apply
at all to that at any time you want to
be on that like I think it's valued you
could use that in that way you could use
jazz dock with typescript to help you
with any the gradual kind of typing
crazy things like that works but and I
like that because it's totally opt-in
but if you're using typescript then why
not there's actually a library so
recently there was a I think it's called
like TS graph QL graph yes where someone
has actually done a project where it's
like a merging of those two things so
might be worth checking out if you're
into the live script
yeah yeah yeah no again I think like if
you follow Mateos advice of like never
change your schemers then that's easy
but if you ever want to change a schemer
like the more you kind of enforce those
types the more places there are to
change and the harder it gets
and yeah you might even graphically well
as well as I said I wouldn't I wouldn't
I would use it when I had no other
choice because as soon as you start
using it you have overhead so like when
I'm green fielding I'd say don't do
graph QL until you get to this place
where you kind of think okay the
complexity here is running a little bow
control so now we need to use graph QL
unless the project your green fielding
is a back-end project where with no
front end component that the
organization is separated in such a way
that the front-end team never wants to
interact with the backend then there's
no full stack say there might be a
mobile T my dock in that case it makes
sense your graph go from the start
because then they can always define
exactly what they want
and I bring you to work hmm yes of
course yes of course come to the booth
we can talk huh sorry say again when you
say like a shaking on the server on the
client is there anybody stuck on the UI
yes you could do that you could do that
but we want to set the name because we
want to display it as well yeah so we do
it we take an extra step but you could
do that yes
eight by five minutes anywhere any point
been apart for no could introduce it now
I would just go through do you think do
you think okay so have you got any
questions
hmm yes yesterday sorry the rice
okay yeah that's off you is a forward
local testing is there a wave like a
pattern in place for making use query
and use me to mutation return I would
recommend to use just a mop just mocked
sound it is there is some some track
some stuff on there on your wrong but
it's yeah that's a react way of doing
things I know man I just don't like it I
know but I know you don't like it yeah
and I agree with you though if the right
way that we actually have doing things
just used as much but the reason is some
more discussion about this in the readme
a son and if not open an issue and we
can
any other questions a couple more things
that are interesting in this workshop so
I'm going through them very quickly
first of all it's you know to be some
pagination how to implement pagination
in this is a concept it needs to
implement Avenue everywhere and you need
to drink reinvent the wheel with a graph
you out to some extent so you know
another way of doing pagination so
please check it out I'm not going I'm
going very quickly so I'm just yeah
this is just in case you want to
continue in your in time and pop I was
crushing my five is caching again very
important pipe piece
unfortunately the SQL it cites SAP all
those nice things about HTTP caching so
you might want to do some different
things for caching you know it hasn't
died some side effect so I'm not going
to go through that much but there is
some some caching and so on so forth
and if you want to go forward the needs
server-side rendering which is pretty
important part if you're writing react
applications five six I got a
server-side rendering in general no I
don't want to enter the topic we don't
have much time how much over three
minutes don't server-side render as a
default choice that's all I'm gonna say
yeah if you want to know more why booth
booth and there is another module called
a graphical look such as art that you
can use to piece nice and yeah and blah
blah blah and graphical loops are also
so these were some people that were
involved in helping prepare this because
this was actually a cross cross team
effort yes so this was done by a lot of
people at near forum so if you want just
reach out to all those guys that angles
that hard out
over the course of of this year so it's
a nice project that we started at the
beginning of 20 of 2019 so it's been
growing in done pretty well so I feel
free to free to throw any p oz or issues
all that kind of stuff as usual hope you
enjoyed it you closed a lot of it you
have them on your machine already
indexed go to talk index dot HTML that's
open index dot HTML it doesn't use any
crazy framework for doing slices just an
HTML file you see well I say I think
I'll show about our style but you know
booth
[Music]